faire une interview fin de phrase
alors christophe je vais vous donner des
début de phrase si vous avez voulait
terminer par exemple rires c'est un bon
moyen de 2
poser les bonnes questions je dois tout
à à la méthode ogino la religion c c'est
une vaste rumeurs persistantes depuis
que je suis connue c'est plus facile
c'est plus facile de c'est plus facile
de téléphoner au volant
ouais j'ai grandi entouré de entouré de
parfum et d'amour la nature m'a bien
gâtés au niveau de niveau leur haut
niveau de la séance alors tu veux dire
pour 2006 j'ai décidé d'arrêter de utile
et d'arrêter d'arrêter si l'alcool me
gêne dans le travail à temps laisse la
finir cette vanne à la can en profitent
bien parce qu'elle croit qu'on en 2005
encore un
c'était fini c'est parce que moi j'ai un
amour un tee shirt c'est comme ça là
c'est l'actuel me gêne dans le travail
j'arrête immédiatement
m
alors nous sommes quoi à l'aréna moi ça
fait vers la mecque
moi j'y crois moi pour me détendre je
fais beaucoup de de sport je lis
l'équipe
la france c'est le pays
ta première marche et la précédente
d'aller à la bataille de paris et sur la
proche la france et des pays de 2,2 de
voltaire rousseau hugo et
malheureusement sarkozy là tu vas te
faire un copain je sais qu'arnaud et
j'ai pas l'ump a renommé vous quand même
vous avez pour sarkozy il se trouve
qu'ils s'attaquent est vrai problème et
propose de vraies solutions et pas
simplement de mettre les choses sous le
tapis en attendant que ça passe
bon il ya ce mérite là et on peut pas
lui ôter
oui je pense pile-poil inverse qu'elle
aime beaucoup mais on peut pas dire à
temps il a raison pas dire qu'ils
mettent les problèmes sous le tapis
c'est vrai mais pas de problème pour y
poser les bonnes questions il a les
mauvaises réponses pas exactement la
bilan qui est du vent du début à la fin
à la faim ce mec est un courant d'air et
je pense qu'en plus il est il est
parfaitement dangereux
alors on continue vous finissez mes
phrases 1 je suis fan de 2
non je suis fan de dodo personnes poteau
aznavour peut-être aussi j'adore ça nous
fait encore
tu vas prendre l'ascenseur je pourrais
me reconvertir dans dans peut-être dans
la politique
si j'étais dieu je ferais je fais mon
dieu si j'ai je ferais je ferai quelque
chose pour que que mon fils ne meurt pas
dans ses souffrances atroces enfin
j'aurai au moins vacciner contre le
tétanos ou la seule fois où je me suis
fait [ __ ] c'est ben c'est sans doute
la première fois où j'ai tourné le dos à
un banquier
alors attention la force de laurent
ruquier c'est à ces de m'avoir engagé
non je pense le rock et c'est vraiment
d'être sympa avec je crois tout le tout
le monde et de dd c'est tout l'intérêt
de se faire ou se faire contredire
violemment
donc
2 le côté écouter aussi voilà ce qui est
impressionnant chez stv c'est ça c'est
sa mère c'est sa mère l'en je le dis
sérieusement à sa mère que j'ai
rencontrés qui est une femme adore à
bord ah ouais mais lui aussi
lui aussi d'ailleurs gré la plus grande
erreur de ma vie c'est la grand-mère de
signer peut-être une volée j'aimerais
bien avoir une plus grosse ou plus
grosse grosse mais ne tiendrait pas dans
l'ascenseur thierry tu m'excite quand tu
alors tu m'excite tu sais que quand
c'est quand tu lui poses des questions
que cette écoute les t'écoute les
réponses c'est souvent tu fais
avec sept sahraouis et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu